this is so hard to watch again
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be picking up where we left
off a year ago and checking in on
youtuber amberlynn reeve now before we
get into it you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
of course please don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
on an episode and if you're not already
definitely follow me at abby's kitchen
over on instagram and tick tock now if
you missed my previous review on
amberlynn be sure to check that out
right here first but to quickly recap
amberlynn started her channel to
document her weight loss journey and has
dabbled in nearly every diet under the
sun since however despite her efforts
she continues to struggle with binge
eating disorder which in turn has
resulted in additional weight gain and a
horribly vicious cycle of online
bullying and fat phobia so in today's
video we'll be following up on amberlynn
and also taking a look at where she is
right now both from a nutrition and
recovery standpoint but before we get
into some of her current meals i want to
take a look and comment on some of the
clips from her response to my response
yes we're responding to a response to a
reading a response huh
i'm impressed it's gonna get intense
it's sad to know that food completely
has ruined my life and i regret so much
it is hard it is so hard
to have this food addiction and this
binge disorder to think that food made a
tour i can't even have a child
i didn't know she was gonna bring out my
cancer i didn't and i hate thinking
about the fact that i had cancer and i
hope that i don't anymore so it's like i
try to never think about it and the fact
that she keeps bringing it up it's like
it almost feels like every time she
talks about it i'm like being smacked in
the face and i guess i kind of deserve
it
that's so hard to watch
so
i admittedly didn't watch this response
video when it was posted like a year ago
exactly and i full out like full out
sobbed the other day when i wash it for
the first time and i'm still obviously
very emotional just seeing her face and
hearing those words
so for one i'm very sorry that i
triggered amberlynn about that cancer
diagnosis i feel very strongly that she
does not deserve it like she says and
i'm sorry if other healthcare providers
have made her feel that way but i know
what it's like to feel responsible for
your own infertility
toward obviously you know my eating
history is different than amberlynn's
but it landed me in a very similar place
and while the outcome on my fertility
you know wasn't as finite in that i
still have my uterus and no one said
with certainty that my ed caused my
infertility but i feel
in my heart that it's very likely that
it played a role because i had chronic
um and menoria and
thin uterine lining which really made it
hard for me to conceive it's triggering
for me too she's right to be honest i'm
very all about low calorie even if it's
like not the right type of food for me
okay let's compose ourselves
i'm glad that some of the things i said
here were eye-opening to amberlynn
because you know it's very common for
chronic dieters to always be thinking
less is always more but you know this is
actually one of the biggest weight loss
mistakes that i see people make as it
can contribute to like a very sluggish
metabolism and it tends to create the
perfect storm for a binge not to mention
you know chronically under eating is
devastating to folks with binge eating
tendencies so this is really like a
double whammy for amber lynn
why is it okay for people to
judge me make fun of me aka binge
monster and all these things and
invalidate the fact that you know i do
have eating disorder i do have food
problems but then if it's like a skinny
person with these problems people don't
ever make fun of them that's something
that i just like i don't understand it's
not fair it's very hypocritical
yes
this 100 this i mean one of the most
obvious examples of fat phobia is this
right here that you know if that person
can be hated on for having an ed but a
skinny person is given support empathy
and care or the example that i gave in
my last video you know with the public
reactions to mukbangs online you know we
see like slim fit always hungry we'll
eat 10 000 calories and viewers will
cheer her on but fat amber lynn eats
like a normal meal or a small meal
that's like salad and she's basically
given death threats it's [ __ ] up and
if you don't see that it's up you are
part of the problem sorry for the tough
love but yeah it's bad and i feel for
her on that one wow this is like making
me realize that i only ever eat out of
emotional hunger i've always thought of
my weight as a symptom of something else
and it's most definitely a symptom of my
binge eating which then in fact in my
opinion is a symptom of something even
higher i'm going to talk about this
shortly when we look at some of her
recent meals and also you know i don't
know amberlynn personally or
professionally obviously but generally
speaking yeah like binge eating and
resulting obesity is rarely a result of
food just tasting really good or having
a really big appetite you know eating
becomes this ineffective coping
mechanism used to suppress negative
emotions that maybe we don't have the
tools to otherwise manage and therefore
losing weight is a lot more involved
than just shrinking portions or buying
locale ice cream i read these comments
as a job i feel like it's important that
i do read the comments here and there
and it they make me feel unworthy and
like i'm not good enough of good things
and it just puts me in a really dark
hole i just want to be normal
i want to be normal i want to be that
person and just knowing that i never
will be is so
it's so hard to wrap my head around i
know that a lot of people will call out
amber lynn as being a troll and that
she's making herself sick and sabotaging
herself for the sake of views and ad
revenue on youtube but how can you watch
someone crying here wishing that they
had a normal life and not think to
yourself you know wow even if this is
just one percent truth this is
heartbreaking and i don't know if it's
like the mom and me but i'm having just
like this real maternal reaction to this
and i imagine my own kids feeling
unworthy and unnormal and i would be so
mad at the world for making them feel
that way so
amber lynn if you are a real person and
this is not like a youtube click scheme
for views like everyone says and you
want to talk to someone reach out reach
out anytime i'm always happy to talk in
the meantime here i do want to show all
of you a recap of some of my overarching
recommendations from her diet review
from last year so in terms of my overall
thoughts on amberlynn's diet at least
based on what we're seeing in these 2020
what in a day videos her portion sizes
are not particularly big in fact at
times they might just not be big enough
and that can set you up for a binge
really quickly but we do have some
generally balanced meals to work with
there is of course some room to optimize
the nutrition in some of amberlynn's
meals particularly to ensure that she is
satiated and then not setting herself up
for a binge with inadequate calories at
meal times and also to make sure that
she's getting in the antioxidants for
cancer prevention so for example adding
in extra nutrition from protein and
fiber would help to make her meals more
satiating keeping her blood sugar levels
in check and of course helping to keep
her fuller for longer without adding in
a ton of calories which may potentially
reduce the urge to binge later on in the
day also focusing on lots of colorful
fruits and vegetables whole grains beans
and soy protein may help to reduce her
risk of future cancer okay so with that
in mind let's take a look at some of
amberlynn's recent what i mean days the
time of filming starting with some
breakfast so for my first meal which is
breakfast i will be having two slices of
turkey bacon avocado toast it's like an
oat nut bread which is so delicious
obviously the avocado an egg moment and
cholula you guys know me one of my main
pieces of advice for amber lynn from my
previous review was to use my hunger
crushing combo in meals so basically we
want to ensure she's feeling
state-shaded and satisfied so she
doesn't need to make up for calories
lost with a late night binge and i am
seeing some good balance at play here so
we've got protein from the egg and the
turkey bacon we've got some healthy fats
from the avocado and of course we've got
some fiber rich carbs in the bread some
other examples of amberlynn's breakfast
include waffles with peanut butter or a
bowl of packet oatmeal each served with
a side of turkey bacon these meals do
have some hunger crushing compounds in
the mix but i do think that there's room
to actually add more the portions that
seem pretty small especially that
oatmeal bowl which definitely wouldn't
hold me for very long which suggests
that there may be some metabolic
suppression and blunted hunger and
fullness cues at play but nutrition wise
these meals range from about 280
calories to about 400 and they're all
under 15 grams of protein and we do know
how important a protein rich breakfast
is for satiety and weight management if
that's her goal in a situation like this
i would be keen to keep slowly edging
that breakfast meal up in calories and
protein to try to stimulate those hunger
and fullness cues so we could do like a
side of greek yogurt with the waffles an
extra egg with the avocado toast some
protein powder in the oats or a protein
smoothie on the side for any of them and
i would also use the opportunity to
maybe sneak in some extra produce with
some fruit for some micronutrients and
extra fiber let's take a look at a
standard lunch i'm gonna have a tv
dinner it's saffron road chicken biryani
with basmati rice i'm also gonna make
some green beans i like to have a super
simple lunch so i'm cooking the green
beans on the stove i added onion powder
minced onion garlic salt black pepper
and tapatio here are the green beans
here's the chicken birani if i'm
smells so damn good
amberlynn often leans on frozen
microwave dinners like this chicken
biryani rice bowl or on other days she
does like a kale pasta or a curry
chicken so in the chicken biryani
example we've got some protein from the
chicken we've got carbs from the rice
maybe there's a bit of fat in there in
the sauce but generally like most tv
dinners we're looking at a meal that is
low in volume so it's also low in fiber
and vegetables and because it is quite
small this is again some evidence that
there may be some metabolic and hunger
cue damage going on but i love that she
bulked this meal up with some green
beans on the side and i would love to
see her utilize that same technique any
time she opts for one of these frozen
convenience meals not only does this
little addition boost the fiber and the
micronutrients and the volume but the
potassium in the vegetables like spinach
tomatoes broccoli or asparagus can also
help to counter balance the higher
amounts of sodium in these kinds of
meals i think sodium recommendations are
definitely a contested area of knowledge
right now but excess sodium is known as
a risk factor for hypertension in some
populations and it may also contribute
to unwanted water attention which could
throw off any potential weight loss
progress on the scale so in this case
the chicken birani lunch provides almost
half of amberlynn's daily sodium
recommendations for the day and only six
percent of her fiber so if you want to
use canned vegetables like she did just
make sure you're going for a no salt
added variety or one thing that i always
do is i would just add in like a bowl of
frozen vegetables into the microwave
while her meal is cooking and then you
can just kind of mix them all together
into the residual sauce all right let's
move on to amberlynn's snacks i love
green olives and black olives but i'm
about to have
large olives so that is
what i've been snacking on is having a
few
pickles i prefer the baby pickles
they're literally the best texture ever
i'm going to have peppered beef jerky
normally i have something sweet at the
end of the night like a frozen yogurt so
emblem will usually snack on pickles
olives or beef jerky which she says can
help to satisfy her salty craving for
chips and while they may have fewer
calories and fat than chips depending on
the portion they often also contain even
more sodium per serving than like
lightly salted chips but rather than
taking any of these salty snacks away we
can give them my hunger crushing combo
treatment by pairing them with a handful
of unsalted nuts or seeds this will not
only provide some protein and some
healthy fats for increased satiety but
they're also a great source of potassium
which as i mentioned earlier will help
to balance some of the excess sodium
content now for a sweet fix amblin
reaches for pineapple or some chocolate
greek yogurt bite now these are great
lower calorie options but again we can
bump up their staying power by pairing
them with a bowl of cottage cheese or
greek yogurt for some protein and fat
lastly let's move on to dinner guys so
right now i'm cooking some chicken
because i'm having a chicken salad
tonight all right so here's my salad we
have some kale sunflower seeds the
chicken
and this is like a poppy dressing moment
okay so as a dinner one night amberlynn
does a pre-made kale salad mix with some
chicken so here we've got some protein
in the chicken fat in the seeds and
dressing and some fiber in the green now
if this is enjoyable and say cheating to
amberlynn great but a lot of folks who
struggle with binge eating or overeating
episodes find that these low carb meals
often leave them physically and or
psychologically unsatisfied which in
turn triggers a binge so i would love to
see some carbs in the mix so maybe
adding in some precooked quinoa or sweet
potato or stuffing it into a whole green
pita now on other nights amberlynn does
a chick-fil-a chicken lettuce wrap with
a little sriracha mayo for dipping or a
bowl of turkey meatballs with rice and
steamed broccoli i love these meals i
mean we aren't skimping on comfort or
flavor or protein or carbs and we got a
little veggie action in the mix so if we
keep this general formula in our head
you know we want to get some protein and
some fat with some kind of meat and fish
or poultry or vegetarian protein we want
to make sure we're getting some carbs
with like noodles rice potatoes bread or
quinoa and then any vegetables that you
like i think we'll find ourselves better
able to get to bedtime without
overwhelming night cravings now with all
that said what are my overall thoughts
on amberlynn's diet so i would say that
we're seeing some mild improvements from
my last assessment namely more meal
consistency and some generally balanced
meals but as i said in my previous
review i still feel that she's under
eating i know everyone sees a person in
a larger body and assumes that they must
be eating like 5 000 calories a day but
often as we can see here that isn't
actually the case it looks to me like
amberlynn is eating as little as 1200
calories a day with just not enough
protein fiber calcium iron potassium or
other important nutrients and the
potassium piece is again so critical
when sodium intake is higher like it is
here and despite not being a lot of food
ambulance doesn't really seem to be
phased by this likely because of some
metabolic and hunger cue disruption now
i spoke to my colleague alessandra
magisano who specializes in eating sores
like bed and while she suggested we
generally don't recommend weight loss in
eating disorder treatment she said that
it can be very carefully done in certain
situations but it would require a very
skilled clinical team to be done safely
now even if weight loss was indicated
and safe as a goal alessandra suggested
in her clinic it would be very very rare
to ever start a patient or client below
1500 calories due to the risk of
perpetuating that metabolic damage so
while amberlynn isn't my client and
therefore my recommendations are not
specifically for her in a scenario like
this my focus would likely be on putting
the intentional weight loss and the idea
of restriction on the back burner so
that we can really focus on building up
that body trust through adequate
nutrition and that means we actually
work up to eating more so more calories
more protein more carbs more fiber
and of course i want to acknowledge that
amber lynn is slowly making some headway
here by no longer relying on crash diets
for quick weight loss but when her
knee-jerk reaction is to restrict
further when she doesn't hit her monthly
weight loss targets we do continue to
see that deep-seated diet mentality
emerge and again while i really do
empathize with amberlynn's strong desire
to lose weight to improve her quality of
life and her mobility and overall health
i think it's really important to be
working with an eating disorder team on
a safe and supportive strategy
a strategy that doesn't risk long-term
metabolic health issues malnutrition or
sustained disordered eating tendencies
so some gentle nutrition tips for
someone like amberlynn might look like a
making sure that meals are consistently
balanced and we're adding protein to
breakfast and snacks some veggies to
lunch and some carbs to dinner b
focusing on variety and diversity which
will also help to balance out some of
the excess sodium from some of the
convenience type meals and see
increasing portion sizes over time until
we start to feel hunger and fullness
cues emerge so while these
recommendations do not explicitly focus
on weight loss over time they may
potentially encourage weight loss in a
more sustainable and supportive way
without the scarcity mentality and on
that note that is all that i have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who you'd like to
review next subscribe to the channel and
i'll see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]